hi guys I'm Erik Bosse and the recent
trailer for Avengers infinity war gave
us our first real look at danos his
black order of all the screen
adaptations of Marvel characters we
probably know the least about these guys
but since they'll clearly play major
roles in infinity war namely trying to
ruin picture day for each of the
Avengers let's explain who each of these
figures are what they're comic backstory
is and who might be playing them in the
movie and what role they might have in
the infinity war story and yeah spoiler
warning in case you don't want to know
anything about anything but still click
on videos about things that you
supposedly don't want to know anything
about okay so the black order is
relatively new in the Marvel Comics they
first appeared in 2013 as part of the
Infinity storyline of a New Avengers
comics they are a team of lieutenants
who assist Thanos in invading Earth for
the infinity gems and tracking down
thanasis illegitimate son Thane
they consist of Corvus glaive the leader
his wife Proxima midnight
evany MA and Corvis his brother black
Dorf who's being called call obsidian in
the movie slow confusing in the comics
the whole group is referred to as call
obsidian there's also super giant from
the order in the comics who won't be in
the movie now in the infinity war movie
the group is being called the Black
Order they're also referred to as
children of Thanos over his ears
conquering various different worlds
Thanos recruited tributes from each of
these defeated civilizations as his
adopted children this is also the
backstory of characters like Gamora and
nebula in a sense the two of them are
half-siblings to all of these black
order figures as well so these four are
Thanos it's generals the best of the
best kind of like how Nick Fury
assembled the Avengers but um these ones
are or jerks so let's break down each
one first Corvus glaive as the leader of
the Black Order Corvis has enhanced
strength and he's a brilliant war
tactician but the key to his power is
the glaive that he carries as long as
this glaive stays intact he cannot die
like in the comics he gets obliterated
at one point but his glade gets encased
in amber allowing the fragments of his
body to bring him back to life this
Glade is super powerful it's used to mop
the floor with the x-men in the comics
it can split atoms in half it can cut
Hulk's skin and in the infinity war
trailer you can see him using it to claw
the mind stone out of visions 4head so
essentially with this new
across the battle line Hulk envisioned
two of the most powerful Avengers are
now nothing well not nothing just you
know a little less special moving on to
the next member of Proxima midnight she
wields a special spear that was forged
by Thanos himself in a star trapped in a
quantum singularity things this allows
the sphere to transform into light and
change its size it hardly ever misses
its target that's why it's such a big
deal to see Captain America dodge and
grab this spear in the trailer now I'm
not sure if the spear will have all of
its shape-shifting abilities in the
movie but either way this isn't supposed
to be something you can just catch then
again the Infinity Gauntlet with the
space and power stones loaded in isn't
supposed to be something you can push
back on either
so essentially cap is a guy or maybe he
has a soul stone go check out my full
in-depth breakdown of the trailer for
more info on that theory oh by the way
you should also go watching for an
explanation of what I think is really
going down when Proxima midnight points
her spirit Loki in the trailer morning
it might come out but to me the most
interesting member of the Black Order is
ebony ma he's essentially just a liar
and a manipulator in the comics he
completely breaks dr. strange which is
huge because historically dr. strange is
always the most powerful minds in the
Marvel Universe looks like the movie is
adapting that directly showing ebony maw
creepily shushing strangest screams as
ma uses Strange's own mystical shards to
stab a space yes in the first trailer we
also saw a quick shot of ebony moss
stepping over some corpses so I predict
the Avengers with more mystical powers
like Scarlet Witch and yeah Doctor
Strange
will be particularly at risk to
themselves and to be weaponized against
other Avengers when Emma Dee mom gets a
hold of him the last member of the Black
Order is Cole obsidian and he's really
the brute of the group as black dwarf in
the comics he was the one to lead the
invasion of Wakanda and it's a little
hard to tell from the trailer footage
but I'm guessing we will see him in this
big battle leading the army of Thanos
outriders his skin is impenetrable so he
wouldn't make a good match for the hole
he also carries a battle ax type weapon
which would be really fun to see go up
against Thor and the new battle axe
weapon he's getting in this movie
Stormbreaker overall it looks like the
purpose of this team in this movie is to
neutralize the threat of the most
powerful Avengers like Doctor Strange
vision
Scarlet Witch Hulk and then leave it to
the more broken grounded and pragmatic
heroes to use their wit stout smart
Thanos and their resilience to overwhelm
them now one of the best-kept secrets of
infinity war is who is playing these
characters marblehead Kevin Feige has so
far only promised that there are
interesting people doing the voices
you'll probably know when you see the
movie of course by the time you're
watching this video maybe this news has
already been revealed but for now here
is what we know
British actor Tom Vaughn Lawler is
performing the physical motion capture
for ebony ma a set photo showed him in
one of those you know stupid silly
looking suits crouching over Benedict
Cumberbatch
but based on Peggy's statement I'm
guessing we'll hear some more famous
voice actors voicing the characters one
of them could be peter dinklage tyrion
lanister from Game of Thrones his name
surprisingly appeared on the recent
infinity war poster my guess is he'll be
boys seeing Corvus glaive or ebony maw
this teasing shush spy every ma looks
like it would be fun to match with
Dinklage's matter-of-fact voice now
there were some other rumors floating
around that Mark Hamill would voice
Corvus glaive Whoopi Goldberg would
voice Proxima midnight and Bill Nighy
would voice evany mah but those rumors
were not confirmed
honestly they sound like they were made
up by fans of Hamill's work and Batman
the Animated Series and Whoopi in The
Lion King and Nighy as Davy Jones I mean
if we're just gonna suggest random
Disney voice actors why don't they get
Gilbert Godfried to do all the voices
not distracting at all
here's my question for you guys which of
the members of the Black Order do you
think will be the deadliest in infinity
war comment down below to let me know
your theory and tweet me directly I da
vas and follow me rockstars on Twitter
for updates on our videos like this
video and subscribe to new rockstars for
everything you need to know about
Avengers infinity war and yeah go check
out my in-depth breakdown for all the
Easter eggs and details you missed you
don't want to miss out guys
how you feeling that bomo sayno mode of
that foam Oh anyway thanks for watching
bye